welcome to this video Grandmaster are GU
koi yeah here we go I got a ready ready
gambit wow I already have a good score
against the sky three and a half out of
four so what do we get it looks a bit
like he's playing the closed set up
against the Catalan but there is a
difference here really this is not the
Catalan yet okay quick a form a quick a
form that's an interesting way to do it
hmm
III is the normal response typically but
after a 4b 4d c4 I'm dropping a pawn I
have 95 though yeah I think 95 is
actually quite good so i can i can do
that i'd like to have before I against a
form okay so he's not not following up
on it it will also questionable I think
it won't before wow really hmm that is
very unexpected I think that's more
weakening than then useful but ok we
will see okay one important idea is to
go before at the right moment for white
and one now I should start Queen B 1 or
before immediately it's not not yet on
let's do creepy one the idea is to play
really before like before a bab Bishop
before Bishop have six wins apiece but
he can go before himself okay he doesn't
um hmm I can also play Bishop g4 now
interesting 95 also comes into
consideration Roxy won't have many
interesting rules before it's not really
on right takes takes Bishop before
Bishop f6 bishop d 2 54 and I'm winning
okay okay then I'm going before then I'm
going before I took me far too long
because it is a desirable move actually
I want to keep is a 6 Bishop bad them
okay don't tell me I miscalculated
Bishop takes before and have blundering
upon it would be kind of embarrassing
but I don't see it no ok so here I'm
going for Bishop up to default and Queen
to be true that's just nice controlling
the long diagonal I is it taking it like
that wow that I missed entirely it's a
fairly unnatural move but it's a good
move
oh wow that's not good
hmm
ah wah wah that's bad news came
what is stupid stupid pong blunder I
couldn't really couldn't keep the pawn
simply but I don't think now Kaiba
should be four words of course rubbish
then but did I had F bishops III may be
a bishop to see three and then quit me
too that was bad i am okay anyway it
continues and it's not not that simple i
hope
if he has to give up the dark squared
Bishop there on d 2 I might have some
play on the dark squares athlete at
least a little bit maybe you can take
and go if I have some butts okay how
does he keep the pawn them hmm no that's
still maybe maybe that's not so easy
considering that I really just bland at
the pawn it's not not so bad yeah yeah
it's it that's not something you don't
like to take it but he had to in some
way okay so what is happening here I
have to move the bishop but where may be
here right DFD for maybe he can go t
four actually well I couldn't go to e3
do tonight reform so I think
yeah but i have but i have Knight to f3
now right checking if five and he'll
have 95 getting one back at least one
pawn Bishop g2 97's the point
I'm actually winning winning i'm at the
end i'm up at porn quite honey we win
deform
I don't think it was so easy actually
with them oh I cannot shake now I so I'm
not winning upon at least not
immediately I cannot play we should be
too okay that's actually quite quite a
problem so what am I playing I can have
to have to use the open file against up
for Luke c7 or something like that
what's shaking him shake I'm morning
should be too
let's do that look before Bishop e3 it's
quite quite neat but it's not going to
fall for that so I'm going to try to
activate my rookie em up to be six
to be sick song or d6 something like
that okay taking away a 5 square up for
King f3 difficult position or now I can
do this it was one point down now I'm
two pawns up that's nice check yeah it
was it was a bit stupid to go down but
it's no no big issue check check let's
see how to do that it's a bit
uncomfortable I can do this though I
think check black for fits on time damn
that wasn't a good name but I could
somehow stage a comeback I like my
position here because I think black
screen side is a bit weak my position is
very compact I think he should go for
before himself actually but he didn't do
that okay I got this in but it's maybe
in view of what happened it's may be
questionable i was thinking i get i get
control now but i don't simply can i do
this actually like here
okay for now that's okay for black a
problem but this is just stupid yeah the
only thing is it's got funny the
computer actually thinks it's okay for
me after that it gives equal yeah to be
honest I had this hunch that it's not so
bad Bishop a 7 kappa vian move didn't
think about it come up off wounds Agathe
nice 1974 let's have this has been on my
channel Bishop a seven but ok that's a
different thing here but it's quite
funny it's the same idea but okay that
was too too much in a blitz game for me
at least yeah and now I thought and
maybe okay I expected not that expected
this 94 and I thought okay I would
probably probably get this back somehow
and my bishops are pretty active on the
engine is giving white a slight
advantage but okay I didn't think it's
like that but I thought okay at least
I'm not dead yet after blundering upon
but this is just giving it away I think
I mean it looks it doesn't look good now
I actually really thought I wouldn't
deform but I don't what is the comp
giving King f3 yeah just running up with
the king yeah that's a good idea sure
why not I interesting now I didn't I
didn't have that idea and also it gives
it that sets really interesting let's
actually said something that I thought
of during the game in general terms at
least if i should play III or not
because well this bishop it's kind of a
strange situation it attacks the spawn
and therefore kind of ties the rook to
the defense of the pawn so this seems
like a fair deal but the bishop is also
well it's on a one it's on a relatively
close diagonal
and as long as the bishop is there I
cannot move my rook so the question is
is III an idea and it's an interesting
way to play just just this now my bishop
is open I can get it to d4 very nice
position in the middle of the board and
maybe I can really get the pawn that's
an interesting thing III maybe that's
really better okay I try to maneuver
here a little bit and enter with the
rook I don't I don't think that is a
particularly great idea know it the idea
here just hit blundered deform it's not
easy to play this position well the
engine is already giving why the huge
edge yeah the night is also somewhat
dominated yeah this is why I entered
with the rook and look before is always
failing to this stupid move yeah it was
a bit lucky i blundered before basically
but it didn't it turned out to be not so
not so bad okay well thanks for watching